no question about it the best comfort
food is definitely homemade wonderful
smells filled in the kitchen delicious
freshly cooked food and a big side order
of nostalgia for me fantastic stews hot
pots and puddings will always hit the
mark and remind me of my mum that's why
i love them my ultimate comforting
dinner is a real favorite in our house
and i hope
it will always remind my kids of me
[Music]
and joining me in the kitchen to cook
the comfort food of my childhood is my
youngest daughter tilly
my ultimate comfort food dinner is a
stunning sausage hot pot which will
serve with a gorgeous potato and
beetroot gratin
now i love hot pot you love hot pot
and you love sausages right yeah
what you enjoy most about sausages
um i just love having them
with a baked beans sometimes with baked
beans sometimes these are
little button mushrooms okay you just
take them into there like that
and keep them whole and cut them into
quarters please
now the important thing about cooking
sausages is they need a bit of color
right no color no flavor exactly get the
pan
nice and hot
how was school today school was good
thanks we got to go out and make snowmen
sausages in
okay butter mushrooms in there please my
daddy
see
now
i want you to wash your fingers but you
know how to slice onions right
definitely i'll be okay now
sausages
i get in lots of color because this is
going to cook slowly
and it's sort of daddy's version of
the kind of hot pot the other one
nannies to make for me yeah once you've
got the color on them
and take them out
rest okay
a little normal butter okay into the pan
now it looks like a lot of onions right
yeah as they start sweating down they
caramelize
so that will go down by half
give that a little fry
okay
salt in
i want you to put a nice tablespoon of
brown sugar in there that gets them
really nice and dark now get your thyme
in
pick off all the little buds
that will get the onions
packed with flavor mmm that's not nice
nice mushrooms in give them a nice
little stir did you like to help them
make your hot pot when she made them for
you i used to always help them make the
hot pot
always
now my mum would never have used this
but a's balsamic vinegar brings out the
flavor of the onions right now look at
our onions
look beautifully caramelized
the vinegar has given that nice sort of
gloss i'm going to put my sausages back
in here now from there
some red wine
red wine
in got the flavour underneath there
going into the sausages now the sausage
is going to release all that flavor
inside as well look at the color of that
does that look pretty good
and it's still not cooked yet up to the
ball really important to boil it here
because it won't ball in the oven 170
in the oven literally
18 to 20 minutes then she goes
nice
to go with my hot pot rich golden creamy
potato gratin it's a true comfort food
classic and i'm adding a delicious twist
beetroot
start by gently heating double cream
[Music]
then peel and thinly slice potatoes and
cook beetroot
next rub garlic around the edge of your
dish to thoroughly season with a
glorious flavor then grease with a good
layer of butter
arrange alternate layers of potato
and beetroot
seasoning in between
[Music]
end with a neat layer of potatoes and
pour the hot cream over the top
bake in a preheated oven for an hour or
until the potatoes are tender
[Music]
potato and beetroot gratin a bubbling
beauty of a comfort food dish
now for the apple compote what we need
to do first is to get these peeled
and sliced
i get my pan on to get nice and hot now
let me give you a little taste of that
business thanks for the warning
both so well he blew my head off
they're incredibly acidic
okay and you need to cook them those
wonderful red apples you've got are
called ray burns what other apples do
you know green ones what are they called
um
i'm not too sure what the green one is
another word for your nan
grandma
no
red no pink lady apple no
granny smith granny smith apples that's
right
what we're gonna do
is cook the cooking apples
and
the eating apples together
i love the combination of the tartness
from the brambly cooking apple with the
sweetness of the brae bun get the pan
nice and hot
and sprinkle the bottom of the pan
with caster sugar
three or four nice slices of fresh
ginger and three little cinnamon sticks
i want you to remember that because
we're gonna look for them
okay because once we've used them
and they've worked their magic i need to
pull them out see all the sugar
dissolving definitely now we just let
that go a little bit darker
okay
and then
the place area is quick
doesn't it
give that
a nice little
toss
okay
nice golden color cinnamon in ginger in
so
we're cooking down the apples
butter in
gently cook until the apples soften then
take off the heat
and they go into there what's that
coming out dad so that is a little bit
of the puree i'll show we'll do that in
a minute how many ginger
four four ginger
and three cinnamon three cinnamon out
with a cinnamon
we've got another ginger gingers and we
take
a spoon
of apples
smells so nice how nice does that look
see the colory apples
let's put these in the fridge to get
nice and cold
that's the compost sorted easy now a
simple creamy whip to crown the top
do you separate the egg whites into
there for daddy
all right egg whites are in
great separate
[Music]
and i'll sprinkle the sugar in and then
you turn up the speed
[Applause]
good girl
[Music]
now let's see if you've got a really
nice stiff peak so you lift them up
now that is what i call a nice stiff
peak well done not bad not bad
next in a separate bowl whip double
cream until stiff
nice and slowly
so cream whips so much quicker
yeah
nice that by hand
we're gonna
put some delicious lemon zest
which will make the cream
so much better then sweeten it up with
leftover caramely compot puree
you mix that in nice and carefully
so it's like this apple
butterscotch
now to make the cream even lighter fold
in those whisked egg whites and sugar
egg whites
into the cream
just
nicely fold that in
so you bring your glasses back out
manage the glasses
yep good girl
silly we're on for a treat
open up the piping bag
now twist the end
now you could spoon this in but i want
to just give a nice little lift it also
gives it a nice pattern
lemon on top
back in the fridge
the beetroot and potato gratin
that lovely that's lovely
sausages
finished with a flat leaf parsley now
look at those two beauties
it doesn't get any more comforting than
that does it for one of the best hot
pots
ever tilly that looks amazing
i know well done
this is my ultimate comfort food dinner
sausage hot pot with potato and beetroot
gratin followed by apple compote
food with guaranteed feel-good factor
when i was a kid there wasn't a lot of
spare money in our house to spend on
fancy ingredients but mum was brilliant
at what she did let me tell you so we
had really tasty hearty food great cakes
amazing puddings all made with the
freshest ingredients that's right isn't
it yes
let's get the sugar on their old tongue
we're cooking the kind of food mum
always dished up starting with a family
favorite steamed eight pudding with a
glorious butterscotch sauce
they weren't cool desserts on those days
were they no it was puddings puddings
now
i'm gonna sieve the flower would you
i'll chop here sean chop those dates
please
that was a favorite wasn't it amazing
sew it in
okay but it's almost like an
old-fashioned dessert wasn't this themed
and everything was sort of steam you had
jam really poorly mm-hmm
so the zest the orange makes that really
nice and fragrant so it helps get that
richness to the suit
okay yeah
brown sugar in
this is such an easy recipe
yes looks fantastic on the table
and then treacle
cheek it in
oh look at that
there's something quite
magical about a spoonful of treacle can
you add them in there please
thank you dude i'll crack an egg
lightly whisk it and mix that into the
milk
if i pour in the egg and the milk would
you give that little mix up please yep
thank you
nice
nice and
slow don't go too fast
you see i always used to think that it
was an old-fashioned desert steamed
pudding do you ever remember me
tumbling around your knees trying to
sort of get in there yeah so you like to
lick the ball didn't you all the time
yeah
now
lightly grease
the mold you're always willing to help
but not with washing up some things
never cheat i think i was allergic to
the soap how was your excuse
kids will enjoy this tonight won't they
delicious paper
that goes on so the secret behind the
parchment paper is to keep that nice and
tight tight yep
there we are
good yeah oh hey wash my hand
come on
tightly cover with foil and place in a
pan of water and let it steam for around
two hours with a lid on
are you going to wash up gord
just for once wash up mr ram oh dear
goodness
do you like that smash
mom you handed it to me and you dropped
it come on
whilst mum forces me to break the habit
of a lifetime dude that's the thought
you're washing up it does that to you
here's how to make an amazing
butterscotch sauce to serve with the
pudding
add butter into a pan brown sugar
golden syrup
and a pinch of salt
and vanilla seeds
melt and combine over a medium heat
stir in the cream and simmer until
thickened
that's the taste of my childhood inner
jug right there and it will keep in the
fridge for a week
[Music]
for the main course my all-time favorite
shepherd's pie what's the secret
behind a really good
shepherd's pie
i would think the vegetables you use and
brown in it so we're going to use leeks
and onions and then start browning off
the mince you know no color no flavor
i've never forgotten that you know that
yeah
so
good to have color gotta have color
otherwise it puts that grey tinge on the
shepherd's pie that looks sick greasy
and cheap and nasty
they don't want that do we and i know
you don't do cheaper nasty let me clear
your peelings now huh all right thank
you very much there's no nails in there
now is there no don't be chicken
i remember
your
amazing shepherd's pie
and that lovely little restaurant used
to work in sheep street in stratford
so you never got food sent back
sometimes they complained that there was
no
come on no i'm telling you
you never ever got a complaint no
how long do you work at that restaurant
for
six shoes six years
oh
what are you cooking i'm gonna make okay
i sort of modern version of nanny's
shepherd's pie dad shouldn't manny be
doing the cooking because she's the
better cook excuse me right mum would
you would you chop our onion please
darling yeah oh gosh your eyes are gonna
water um no
daddy what's in this spot sorry
in there we got a delicious steamed
treacle and date pudding let's just
separate it for you
how does skeletons call their friends
how do skeletons call their friends i'm
not too sure on the scalabone i'm just
gonna tilly come on
okay so two cats are in a race one is
called one two three and the other is
called
under 12. who won
john depends who's the fastest cat one
two three because under 12 cats sank
[Music]
oh goodness
tells why do you make a nice cup of tea
for honey you want me to disappear
thank you
bye so give that a little fry off okay
nice
quarter these jokes they get worse oh
she's certainly having a bit of fun
worcester sauce that's gonna give that
really nice spicy seasoning
oh thank you
okay
tomato puree in
you could put a ton of tomatoes in this
if you want you could yeah
put that mince back in there once it's
drained i'm just going to put a little
touch
i know you'll go crazy at this a little
touch of red wine
really
why the red wine well because i'm going
to make it nice and rich
okay
produce the red wine down yeah and then
start covering your mince
with your stock
now i'm going to bring it up to the bowl
okay and then get some fresh rosemary
okay
like a little taste yes please
is it hot
it's a little bit hot be careful
well i don't like the way
i'm sorry
oh god
as it cooks out the wine and the alcohol
will disappear it will be delicious
trust me
now god spring onions we'll chop up
and that's going to go through
the mashed potatoes that's going to sit
on top of that nicer i like that savory
yeah delicious mince that's laced with
all that red wine nice so springer is
into there please mum
and i'm going to drain off the potatoes
hi there hello hello
oh hi jack hi hi hello hello jack have a
nice day school yeah
yeah
so i'm gonna dry out those potatoes and
then mash them nice oh can i mash them
would you okay um holly slice a little
knob of butter in there for jack please
so what was the restaurant you worked
out there were you a chef
cook
i love the diplomacy were you a chef i
was a cook
exactly that
no really
you used to help me with these little
right you kids do
no potatoes
these are nice and fluffy aren't they
aren't they and do you want them little
delicious mashed potatoes yeah with no
lumps in there
hey weren't you getting it
huh
it's great having you back in the
kitchen mommy now yeah huh seriously
brings back good memories
no
just
why'd you do that dad i just want to
fork it to get it nice and spiky
so i want that nice crispy topping
and then lightly grate that cheddar
cheese on top and that goes in the oven
literally 20 minutes 180 minutes jack
can you on the door people
that looks lovely doesn't it
even though you said you didn't like it
earlier okay
back in the day mama's meals all came
with two veg and this is no different
but with a modern twist braised peas and
carrots with a fantastic homemade mint
butter
shepherd's pie
glazed on top that looks lovely doesn't
it and then the carrots
oh seeded coats that's why i didn't put
carrots in let's put them on the side
let's see last job before serving pour
that gorgeous butterscotch sauce over
the pudding
okay i'll take one at a time
that smells incredible
this is my ultimate childhood dinner
shepherd's pie with crispy cheese champ
topping sweet buttery peas and carrots
and a steam date pudding dripping in
butterscotch sauce all that's missing
are the family